[Music]
hey guys i've got a question for you
are you disciplined when it comes to
money
food
studying
exercising time
or work
if you're not then you need to know that
you can never reach your full potential
if you are not disciplined in all areas
of your life
jim rohn said discipline
is the bridge between goals and
accomplishment
that is so true now listen to this it
might not always be comfortable
when you have to discipline yourself in
certain
situations but it is either that little
bit of discomfort
that you have to deal with
or
if you're not disciplined and you don't
reach your goals and you have that
feeling of regret
for the rest of your life
which one would you prefer
that feeling of regret forever and ever
and ever oh i wish i did that
or
now and then just a feeling an
uncomfortable feeling
of discipline
and let me tell you later when you make
it a habit you will love discipline in
your life
discipline is doing what needs to be
done
even when you don't feel like it
this is so important i'm going to say it
again discipline is doing what needs to
be done
even if you don't feel like it
this is where strong men are separated
from the weak
men of conviction men who will do what
is necessary to accomplish their goals
so first to be more disciplined
you need to have goals in your life
what are your dreams
and what are the goals to achieve those
dreams sit down and write this down
write down a list of short-term goals
and then also long-term goals
that you want to achieve
and then schedule your priorities to
achieve those goals for example
long-term goal
i want to gain 15 kilograms this year
short-term goal lose five percent body
fat and gain three kilos of muscle in
the first two weeks priorities work out
six to seven a.m five days a week and
eat a healthy now you need to think of
your goals to stay disciplined every
single day
and you need to be consistent that means
you need to develop it as a habit
to wake up every day and to know all
right i'm gonna work between this time
and this time towards my goal it needs
to become a habit and it cannot become a
habit if you don't discipline yourself
oleg konovalov said
self-discipline means establishing an
authority over one's own habits routines
and priorities and not being under their
control
first you need to make an active
decision you need to decide in your head
that you want to change your life for
the better and then you need to stick to
that decision meaning you need to be
consistent come what may
because listen to this there will always
be ups and downs in this life
that's just how it is but it is your
consistency that will bring you the
results you need for success start to
take control of your life
you are the captain of your ship so
think about where you are steering your
life towards
use your compass your reminder which is
your long-term goal to keep you going in
the right direction no matter what
storms you may face
now listen to this to master your own
life to master your ship you first need
to master your thoughts
and this is not just something that will
happen once it's a continual thing it's
a renewal of mind and it will continue
until the day you die and to master your
thoughts you need four things
one
stop all nonsense from entering your
mind music movies friends everything
that has a negative influence on you
two replace all negative and
unproductive thoughts with good honest
and productive thoughts that build you
up and keep you on the right track
whatever is true whatever is honorable
whatever is just whatever is pure
whatever is lovely whatever is
commendable if there is any excellence
if there is anything worthy of praise
think about these things
three stop wasting time on things that
you cannot change
and beating yourself up for pause
mistakes
instead
just learn from them and move on
four
take a timeout in heated moments force
yourself to calm down
and to think rationally and not
emotionally
if you can master your own mind you can
force yourself to be disciplined and
that will change all areas of your life
even the ones that are unknown the
future
why
because you cannot always change the
situation but you can definitely change
you
in that situation how you think how you
react
and that is powerful
that
changes your whole life it changes
everything
now let me leave you with this quote
suffer the pain of discipline
or suffer the pain of regret the choice
is yours
if you want more self-improvement tips
watch these videos here and i'll see you
there and always remember before you go
life is short
so don't waste yours cheers guys